hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to oxygen not included now
this is the latest game made by the
developers of don't starve and don't
starve together I believe it's
pronounced clay entertainment but don't
quote me on that one but they gave me a
key for an early not even early access
but a pre-alpha build of the game to
test out and I'm really excited about it
because this game supposedly it's kind
of a space survival colony management
death is lurking behind every single
door type game because I may hate the
ocean and some people call me out on my
uh my hypocrisy because space is kind of
the same way it's just a big old ball of
death no matter where you look but I'm
ready to help
Quincy Horatio and Elvira live in this
terrifying dark place known as space so
I want to point out that I've never
played this game before I have no idea
how to play it I've never seen a video
on it so I'm going to be learning from
scratch because there's not many
resources on how to play it in the first
place and I wouldn't necessarily do
anything about that anyway I'm not a
hundred percent sure of what I should do
about this but Quincy seems pretty good
he's a level seven miner Horatio level
one not very athletic but at least
Elvira is pretty good architect so what
am I I've never done this before so I'm
gonna Jack greasemonkey small bladder
[Music]
a lifetime of running is a from his
responsibilities made Jack emotionally
and Bennett able now now I gotta do that
one who a scientist grub things plants
are neat that's good I kind of like that
but I think I can do better Woodrow a
physician might be nice
stress response bomb to the burger oh
man everyone else's stress response is
destructive that's no good
Eleanor oh I like Dancy feed oh hell
yeah
Oh mole hands what that means a severe
climate requires a severe woman this
Eleanor is that woman okay I'm down for
this
I'm down for this I'm gonna I'm an
actually name this guy he's mark
I'm a minor cuz I like digging things at
any given moment a mark his viscerally
reliving 10 different humiliating
memories well that is absolutely the
truth okay name your colony I'm gonna
name this let's just imagine from my
Kerbal space program playthrough that uh
the crashy mix bloaty the crash team
explody turned into a colony in space
after it finally went off into the Stars
and the crashing explody is now the
smashy-smashy Makdessi colony that's
what it is
alright we're real optimistic here this
smash emic deathy colony and hopefully
our let's embark let's go on this I'm
ready for this I'm super ready
all righty then ooh new hope alert your
crew has awoken miles beneath the
surface of an unfamiliar terrestrial
body oddly they have no recollection of
how they got there it might be best to
start digging okay
well oh this is weird so we went through
Oh a printing pod next duplicate what
ration box okay basic controls I should
read this WASD to pay on your camera
mouse wheel to zoom in and out
eights we'll return to the printing pod
simulation can be sped up by using the
top buttons on the left mm-hmm pressing
tab will cycle through them okay space
will pause let's just pause that until I
know what I'm doing colony requires
toilets I'll get to that in just a
second I need to figure out my bearings
because I want to actually learn here
and all I just feel a flail miserably I
mean that's gonna happen anyway but
don't worry about it I'll get to that
duplicates are generally self-motivated
and do not need to be individually
managed in order to form tasks in the
colony you can use the dig tool G and
the build menu in the lower left of the
screen to begin planning job tasks once
you have a few place your duplicates
will automatically get to work for you
they're like The Sims okay all right so
dig obviously we would probably need to
dig through here and connect the dots I
imagine it would be bad if we went too
high because that looks like the cold
deathly vacuum of space and I don't
think we need to go there so let's just
dig a path through here and then oh is
that some sort of mineral that might be
a mineral I'm not 100% sure and then the
build tools which are down here okay
neato oh cool
missing resource raw material okay so
we're basically gonna have to get
materials to build stuff for the smashy
Makdessi colony and then be pretty good
stress pretty low population low
available calories okay good all right
okay so I guess I guess we just go for
it right
all right go for it whoa oh boy
man screw shovels I want a laser gun to
dick through my problems holy
okay but that's cool because what that
means is
all right so bright click to get out of
that what that means is so all things go
into the storage box or is that just the
ration box because we got oxygen going
in there but it's dropping rapidly I
need to get that taken care of soon I
need some sort of power whoa a manual
generator can I have mark just run off
all his problems and I'm just gonna dig
out I'm gonna get this nice nice and
even here it's got a nice
maybe maybe actually open up this
because then we might be able to collect
all these resources while we're doing
this and then they can hurry up their
tasks by speeding it up oh that's so
cool oh I love this and I love don't
starve to death like I love that game
it's absolutely awesome and they're
getting a ton of resources there I don't
know where they're being stored but I've
got a tab for consumable or organic
materials edible raw and then raw metals
so that's copper so that's definitely
copper so let me pause this for a second
so what I need to do I have oh I now
have materials so I can build a manual
generator I'll keep it like I'll keep it
like right here I guess all right then
then electrical wire we'll run that to
whatever I need to power right oh and
then I probably need a battery so I'm
just gonna do this because I'm
experimenting here I don't exactly know
what's gonna go on so I definitely need
to do that and then I'll probably need
an LG condenser right there yeah all
right right there okay and let's see how
that does I don't know if that's gonna
be any sort of good Oh
so the materials just lie on the ground
alright then they're just shooting the
well they're just shooting they're just
shooting nuts and bolts at it
that's even better a laser to
deconstruct anything and then a scrap
gun that's amazing
okay so those are gonna go there and I'm
hoping okay do I need to connect those
with a wire yeah I do okay okay oh so
wiring I thought that was just gonna be
buried in the ground but that's actually
a little bit unconvenient okay so I
missed a found a I just okay I just
ruined everything is there a way to like
put stuff back in that because I just
ruined that I just absolutely destroyed
that I am an idiot that is stupid
how do I put foundation back there okay
I've already screwed up everything I
know that for a fact
you guys just need to calm down do I
need to put red alert on this one
because I don't know that that's
absolutely necessary here everybody just
calm down I'm a bad manager here don't
know what I'm doing all right you know
what I think I got to deconstruct these
because I I i goofed real hard alright
there we go this is I I goofed real bad
I'm sorry
okay so all right so let's just lets it
do this again I'm gonna dig out here and
this is gonna be the area where we kind
of make stuff and then we're just gonna
assume the district's planned okay I can
connect wires directly across things so
they don't need to be out of the way of
anything else so now that I got the
power I can have my little guy yes yes
and then I can have from the from this
too oh I guess I could wow that's that's
not what I wanted
how do I not hole okay right then I'm
just gonna deconstruct this and have
this nearby then because I don't
necessarily need that to be far away I
have that right there and then just wire
it straight across yes yes yes yes yes
maybe I have no idea they're just passed
out that's so adorable why did they all
just fall down at the same time
[Music]
alright then hope y'all don't die in the
depths of space is there like no limit
to oh my god was that
oh that looks scary I don't know if I
wanna have that that looks very scary
okay so there seems to be some sort of
gas over there that's probably gonna
explode and melt our faces off and then
there's probably a whole bunch of other
problems over here this is just pure
liquid blood
oh no this magma oh that actually is
death okay that's good hydrogen
unbreathable but probably a good
resource water which is very important
so we eventually got to get down to that
water cuz I bet we don't have any of
that and we need toilets oh boy we need
toilets okay I should a problem stations
research station medical Cod outhouse
that'd be nice we'll put the outhouse oh
by the by the hydrogen place I can't
can't build there apparently but there
by the hydrogen place that way the
methane the hydrogen will combine and
then the spark will go off and
everything you'll blow up and we all die
that sound good alright so now I just
need to make sure that this is wired up
it is right so is that going a waiting
material delivery oh holy crap he
automatically does it I don't even need
to assign that that's so cool and then
they're gonna build this outhouse right
maybe Eleanor's just waiting like come
on mark
Jesus Christ can't you tell I have needs
jeez Eleanor gosh if you would get off
your lazy ass and actually helped me
build something we're not all artists
like you Eleanor burger oh well they're
hungry all the time to eat they have to
suck they have to suck the food out of
the box they don't know how to use their
hands anymore everything's just done in
their multi-tools
you know what I can appreciate that if I
had a tool that could do anything
destruction and construction at the same
time I wouldn't be bothering with these
old bad boys anymore do my Let's Plays
purely through the power of lasers I get
it you all need to take a you just
go duplicants must have accessible paths
to their jobs in order to work when
placing tasks keep in mind the
duplicants can only climb obstacles two
tiles high and are themselves two tiles
tall
okay then so they can't get up there's
the problem
hmm that's fine that's okay
I know it's ready it's right there
insufficient insufficient resources
what do you mean insufficient resources
what more could you possibly need we
can't get dirt really well there's some
dirt on the ground over there but I
don't know if I want to and I guess we
might as well I guess we need some dirt
suppose all right go for it can I cancel
this one wait I can cancel this order
cancel that ah they fell
wait gonna fall I tell you why you got
you got that ah I'm watching you
there you go nice okay so apparently I
need a lot of dirt to go into that so I
need to actually do some more stuff here
I need to make a food produces low
quality food with low quality
ingredients so I'm just gonna put that
there and hope they dig it out of the
way and then power there we go go for it
[Music]
dude Elvira level up oh yeah go for it
Elvira are we running out of
probably stop getting away okay we got
rations so we don't have a lot of
rations reading some more food real bad
we're doing okay on breathable gas
thankfully okay oh that's cool so that
just naturally distributes oxygen Oh Oh
what is this mush bar or lice loaf may
cause diarrhea with a mush bar
that I think will make lace loaf even
though that sounds absolutely terrible
Oh Mele Weiss dude
all right we're gonna make that I guess
oh so this is a lot more in-depth
than I thought it was gonna be and my
little guys I love you to death
Elvira Elinor and Mark you got to be
just fine if you think that I would let
anything happen to you guys you'd be
absolutely right you are going to die oh
it's okay duplicants will seek out and
collect water and other liquids up to
two tiles away and deliver it to
buildings okay so we got to get down to
that water but we can't just dig
straight down we need to build a path to
it so I need to dig smartly so we're
gonna build we're gonna like minecraft
style this okay and then I'm gonna
build a landing and then we're gonna dig
back down again I wonder if they burn
more calories or something when they're
climbing up and down stuff ah this so
cool I love this I love the automation
oh I reckon cut them off I didn't build
that right well I'm dumb food shortage
it's zero calories of food available Oh
cuz you're far away from it oh no oh
that's not good okay well they don't
have oxygen down there
oh no they're suffocating Oh God ah oh
um okay alright you go up up up up
up up up up
alright
maybe like that maybe they could climb
up that way oh please get up there I did
not do that right I did not do that that
Marsh dead Oh God
Elvira is dead Oh God Eleanor's dead
[Music]
well
I feel awful
terrible I feel awful what have I done
oh dude okay they're all dead
aren't they
they're pretty dead okay they're dead
all right they're dead okay so that
didn't work out too well I'm bad but
either way that'll be the first episode
of oxygen not included I want to do more
of this I want to do a lot more this
this seems really really cool so I'm
gonna play this again resume game
they're dead thank you very much I'm
gonna do this again imma have another
episode of this and maybe a few more
after that because this seems really
cool I love the concept of it
I love management style games like this
and I love games where I can get
attached to the characters and now
they're dead so I'm sad but you know
maybe next time I'll have people that
aren't gonna be so dead that'll be kind
of fun too so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think of it it's down in the comments
below I don't know if you guys are able
to play the pre-alpha just yet but uh if
there is a way I'll provide a link in
the description so that you can try the
game for yourself so thank you again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]